[Applause]
speaking to three-point shooters this
guy can light it up buddy hield
this is it off and family would affinity
buddy hield pumping spitting it's
scoring more than a guy in consist shoot
threes he's got a game to him and roll
with Charlotte yep
if that becomes his role again but he
healed it's working on lamb here and
Buddy hield he'll meet Center trying to
drive around Sabonis it's taken away TJ
Warren with in transition and the runner
calls in for TJ Warren
TJ Warren you mentioned it Tim major a
unique environment in his body
but he'll hits the three water fouled
and get that ball and lead it for that's
the thing about the bonus I mean this is
so practice the defense again by the
Pacers Warren and one and a chance to
cut the lead down the one he raved about
in her staff about this can with this
Sacramento Kings team has gone away the
intensity defensively as far Sampson
here come the Pacers down seven Warren
to three is good robbed it in back he J
Warren time $80 ty gave with 7.8 seconds
to go to national watts this execution
going to the ball side corner the
delivery somewhere on the floor to
defend this guy buddy hield off screens
III got four buddy hield
tied at 128 it's
buddy hield jumper right there to get it
close but then dip it turned it over I
mean what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content